ever since she was in high school Faith
had dreamed of moving out and finally
getting a place of her own it wasn't
that she didn't love her parents she did
but they were always around always
coming into her room without knocking
telling her when to go to bed when to
wake up not to eat dinner in front of
the TV in college she had some welcome
Independence but she had to live with
roommates again they were perfectly nice
people some of them she even considered
good friends but she hated having to
share her space having to come home from
a long day of classes and see someone
else's dishes piled up in the sink to
have someone else's music keeping her
awake at night to delay her morning
shower because someone else had gotten
there first so she was thrilled when a
few years after graduating she got a new
job at a marketing company that would
finally let her afford a place by
herself at last she could have some
peace some quiet and most importantly
some privacy Faith spent all day moving
furniture and unpacking boxes turning
the little apartment into a real home it
wasn't much just a main room she used as
a bedroom and living room a bathroom and
a basic little kitchen but it was all
hers and all of the little personal
touches she'd put together really made
it feel like the place was meant for her
there was the orange couch she picked up
at a vintage store downtown the coffee
table she'd gotten for free from her
last roommate bring pictures of her
family and friends a bed with Linens in
her favorite color light blue and lots
and lots of potted plants over time she
would find even more things more little
personal touches to liven up the space
now how to celebrate her new home her
gas wasn't on yet so she couldn't cook
anything but that was the perfect excuse
to order in 30 minutes or less later she
was kicking back on her couch with a
large cheese pizza watching a scary
movie on her TV no one would asked to
switch it over to the bachelor no one
would take the last slice while she was
in the bathroom it was perfect finally A
Little Piece of Heaven an introvert's
Paradise as she finished her first meal
in the new place she felt her eyes
beginning to grow heavy the day of
strenuous unpacking catching up with her
body just as she was thinking about
calling it a night a pale-faced monster
appeared out of nowhere on screen
terrifying the movie's main character
and making Faith jump spilling her soda
all over the coffee table damn it she
groaned already she'd made a mess but
hey she tried to look on the bright side
it was yet another first to break in the
apartment she grabbed a kitchen towel to
mop up the soda and when she returned to
the main room she froze there was
something in the window standing out
against the darkness outside at first
she thought it was a reflection a trick
of the light but as she slowly
approached the window eyes wide and
trembling she got a better look there
was a face a little difficult to make
out as if it were peering Out of the
Shadows but unmistakable nonetheless it
was pale Hugh
vaguely resembling a strange man with
dark circles under his eyes and he was
looking right at her she didn't scream
she was too terrified to make a sound
she stared at the face for a long moment
waiting for it to do something anything
after several moments of the tenses
staring contest of her life she blinked
the face didn't budge yeah you need to
leave she finally spoke surprising
herself as she did if you don't get out
of here I'm calling the cops again the
face did nothing do you hear me her
voice climbed in Pitch her heart
pounding against the inside of her chest
who was he what did he want she became
vaguely aware of the fact that she
couldn't see the rest of the man's body
just his face looking at her with a
neutral expression a look of vague
curiosity like someone watching a caged
animal at the zoo might have it was then
she remembered something that made her
blood run cold made the towel drop from
her hands as her stomach sank she lived
on the third
her apartment had no balcony no fire
escape he could have climbed up whatever
was looking at her through her window it
was no ordinary peeping Tom she couldn't
say how long she stared at the face its
unblinking eyes it's inscruciable
expression she moved closer to the
window step by step until she was almost
nose to nose with the thing she couldn't
think of it as a person though it looked
like one mostly she should run screaming
out the door looking for some kind of
help but what would she say but there
was a floating face looking at her
through the window what if it was
somehow all in her head some sort of
hallucination brought on by exhaustion
and the stress of the Moon she raised a
fist and following a passive Instinct
wrapped on the glass she didn't know
what she expected for it to Blink to
move to knock back to say something but
nothing happened it just stayed there as
if it were part of the window itself
Faith pulled the curtains closed hiding
the strange face from view with any luck
it would be gone in the morning she had
worked hard to get this apartment and
she would be damned if she let some
strange thing whatever it was drive her
out of her new home but as she climbed
into bed and pulled the covers up to her
chin she could still feel its Gaze on
her as if it could see through the thick
fabric of the curtains she rolled over
onto her side her back to the window and
tried her best to forget about it to
shake that horrible feeling of being
observed she lay there for hours eyes
open heart racing but finally the
exhaustion one and she Slipped Away into
sleep she didn't dream at all that night
it was as if she closed her eyes and
seconds later it was morning she woke to
the beep of her alarm feeling as if she
hadn't rested at all the first thing she
did was climb out of the bed and go to
the window carefully tentatively she
opened the curtains she let out a sigh
of deep relief the face was gone she
must have imagined it after all a bit
concerning but as long as it didn't
happen again she wouldn't have anything
to worry about lack of sleep does
strange things to the mind after all no
longer plagues by the fear of that
strange face faith hopped into the
shower and let the worries of the
previous night wash away disappearing
down the drain she brushed her teeth
dried her hair did her makeup and
dressed for work after a banana and a
quick cup of coffee she was out the door
work was exceptionally busy that day and
it pushed any memory of the Oddity in
the window out of her mind entirely she
was even feeling good enough to accept
her friend's offer to grab a drink after
work they met up at a bar down the
street from her new place sharing
cocktails memories and a plate of onion
rings it was a perfect lovely evening by
the time she got home savoring the click
of the key in the lock as she let
herself into her quiet little Sanctuary
she had completely forgotten about the
unusual Apparition she swung the door
open and rushed to dump herself onto the
couch for a bit of TV before bed then
out of the corner of her eye she saw it
the face back in its previous Place
staring at her from the darkness outside
she gaffed at the sight her screamed
catching in her throat it was just as
she remembered it right no something was
different what was it she clapped her
mouth in horror as she identified the
change its expression was different gong
was the vaguely interested neutral
expression now it was smiling at her not
a pleasant smile not a warm friendly
smile a wicked smile twisted and cruel
it knew she was afraid that she'd been
hoping it was gone forever and it was
enjoying itself her hands were shaking
nervous sweat beating on her brow what
do you want from me she whispered
staring into its eyes they didn't move
but they glittered with malicious Glee
just the same what do you want from me
she repeated her voice rising to a shout
shut up her next door neighbor yelled
banging on the wall it's after midnight
she couldn't bring herself to respond
she had more important things to attend
to her stomach turned bile rising in her
throat with the face begun again in the
morning would it come back again at
night was the apartment haunted
possessed by a specter doomed to reside
in her window forever was that why the
rent had been so affordable or maybe it
was her maybe this thing had been drawn
to her or maybe she was losing her mind
an accustomed to living alone and her
sanity was slipping away she shivered at
the thought what was worse if the face
was on her head or if it wasn't rather
than attempt to answer the question
gnawing at her she closed the curtains
out of sight out of mind she thought she
would have to keep the curtain closed
possibly forever it was better than
seeing that damned face grinning that
horrible grin but as she tried to settle
in for another restless night she could
feel its eyes boring in tour burning
into her skull she had never felt so
uneasy before she prepared for
cockroaches for black mold and for
burglars but not for this this was
something outside of her understanding
outside of reality itself just don't
look she whispered to herself just don't
look at it it became part of her daily
routine wake up ignore the window go to
work try to forget about the window get
home try desperately not to think about
the window she could always feel it
though as soon as the sun went down
though she kept the curtains closed she
knew it was there she thought about
checking to see what face it was making
this time but she couldn't bring herself
to look gradually her condition worsened
she woke up to a tightness in her chest
panic attacks that wrecked her body and
felt like her heart might stop beating
her stomach would ache she struggled to
keep food down one morning she rushed to
the bathroom and spat up blood the
effect began to follow her out of the
apartment too far away from the faces
dwelling she would sit at her desk
struggling to focus on marketing
campaigns and pitches and she would feel
a sudden pain in her stomach forcing her
to double over and groan with Agony she
would see flickers of the pale face in
her peripheral vision turning to look
only to find there was nothing there
when she walked down the hall to the
elevator or down the street outside her
building she would feel as if someone
was following her she never saw anyone
never heard any footsteps coming up
behind her but she could never shake off
the sensation soon even her formerly
dreamless nights of sleep as fitful as
they had been became unsafe she would
toss and turn sweating through her
sheets as her subconscious was tormented
by chilling visions and terrible
nightmares she would dream of walking
down a long dark hallway that seemed to
go on forever and something coming up
behind her trying to grab her and drag
her away it would chase her wide dark
eyes and long long limbs grasping her as
she ran and ran but never escaped other
times she would dream of being locked in
a damp basement chained to a wall as the
pale creature sat in a chair across from
her just watching waiting for something
though she didn't know what every night
another nightmare that made her wake up
screaming fighting off invisible
attackers after two weeks of living in
hell she decided to look out the window
again she had to see had to know that
night when she opened the curtains it
was there mouth wide open eyes glinting
it was laughing at her screw the deposit
enough was enough she wanted her home
back she picked up the heavy lamp on her
bedside table wounded up and threw it
out the window with all her might the
glass shattered little crystalline Shard
sprang in every direction as the lamp
flew through the air out the window and
down to the street below and just like
that the face was gone she checked every
other window in place the little one in
the bathroom the people on her door but
it was nowhere to found she was free her
knees gave out and she collapsed to the
floor her face in her hands and wept
from sheer relief tomorrow she would
clean up the broken glass and spin her
landlord a story about a freak accident
someone would come to fix the window and
it would be the best money she had ever
spent eventually the whole ordeal would
fade away from memory like a bad dream
but somewhere out there someone else was
living the nightmare all over again
looking out to darkened window to see an
unwelcome Guest The Entity known as
scp-965
scp-965 is a phenomenon affecting framed
windows when it appears it manifests in
the shape of a shadowy face belonging to
a pale man staring in through the window
the details of the man's face vary from
person to person as well as his apparent
age and the direction he is facing
however all reports point to the same
figure at various ages ranging from 10
to 55. the foundation has attempted to
use facial recognition software to
identify as citizen matching the
description of this figure but so far no
one has been found
scp-965 will not appear in just any
window it will only manifest when the
lighting on the outside of the window
drops below illumination of five
candalas the lighting on the inside of
the window does not have any measurable
effect the face will only appear in the
confines of a completely assembled
window frame though the window does not
necessarily need to be installed
anywhere it will only move from one
glass pane to another if its original
point of manifestation is destroyed the
face can be seen from an outside vantage
point though it has been described by
observers as looking away into the room
when scp-965 first appears to someone it
produces feelings of unease anxiety and
low-grade paranoia anyone within the
visual range of the affected window will
experience these feelings even if the
window is covered by curtains or any
other means any individual that sleeps
in an area visible to scp-965's
manifestation point will begin to
experience difficulty sleeping suffering
from upsetting and disturbing dreams
however this is not the end point of the
entity's impact on those it appears to
at a point between three and ten nights
of sleep after its initial appearance
the entity's facial expression will
begin to shift into a noticeable smile
after the shift the victim's symptoms
will become physical as well as mental
including ulcers and intestinal bleeding
heartburn abdominal pain and even
vomiting blood this has been attributed
to the entity's influence on the human
body's reaction to heightened levels of
stress and fear the subjects that reach
this stage of exposure to scp-965 begin
to see its face in Windows in their
dreams as well as spotting it in their
peripheral vision while going about
their Waking Life they begin to see the
face out of the corner of their eye even
when the affected window is nowhere in
sight these additional sightings are
accompanied by lingering feelings of
paranoia and The Sensation that
something is following
watching them though the entity has
never made a sound and does not move
while it is visible it can disappear and
reappear in different poses it has also
displayed notable signs of sentience
appearing disappointed when it manifests
in an empty room and angry if it sees
someone who broke its previous window
when presented with one of the agents
who first brought it into custody The
Entity appeared frightened for the first
time testing involving scp-965 involving
the destruction of its host window
confirmed that a multi-paned window
might act as multiple holding zones but
significant damage to its overall
structure keeps it from being a viable
replacement in this particular case the
entity manifested in a nearby
experimentation Chambers observation
window which was promptly destroyed in
order to prevent any potential breaches
for a month following this incident The
Entity manifested with noticeably
hostile facial expressions clearly
resentful of its treatment only one
other notable incident has occurred so
far during the course of
scp-965's containment by the SCP
Foundation Dr Al the rest of her name
has been redacted from the official file
was the head researcher assigned to
scp-965 for several months before she
filed an official request for transfer
to a different test subject she was
beginning to experience intrusive
visions of scp-965 and lingering
feelings of paranoia lasting long after
she left the foundation signed her
symptoms were consistent with those of
someone who had slept in the presence of
the entity though she swore up and down
she had never napped or slept at all in
the vicinity of the affected window she
was temporarily relieved of her duties
and provided with psychological care so
far no other instances of scp-965
impacting staff who have not slept in
its presence have been reported but this
case set an unsettling precedent the
mental health of anyone assigned to
scp-965 is to be strictly monitored in
case it expands its influence again
scp-965 is contained within a framed
ready to install window made up of six
panes of clear glass or other comparable
material at a size of at least 15
centimeters by 30 centimeters the window
must be kept in an environmentally
controlled storage facility capable of
withstanding earthquakes and other
seismic activity the window must be
inspected at least once a week in order
to check the Integrity of the material
additionally at least two identical
framed windows must be stored in the
same facility in separate Chambers with
additional insulation any Lighting in
the containment chamber should be kept
at a minimum of 130 Candelas at any time
Personnel are inside with the exception
of research and experimentation though
scp-965 is currently contained the
foundation is unable to control its
movement should its current window be
destroyed therefore scp-965 is
classified as Euclid scopuphobia is the
fear of being watched or looked at by
others those suffer suffering from this
sphere will often avoid Windows
terrified of who might be standing on
the other side staring in and keeping
track of everything they do even those
of us without scopophobia might find
ourselves feeling a prickle of dread
while looking out the window at night
watching for a shadowy figure or a
ghastly face pressed to the glass most
of the time of course there is no one
there it's just an overactive
imagination the lingering effect of
watching one too many scary movies but
eventually your luck might just run out
one night when the world Falls quiet and
you go to close the curtains before you
go to sleep just in case you might just
feel that someone is right there on the
other side of that thin pane of glass
staring at you with wide unblinking eyes
it won't ever come inside but it isn't
going anywhere and as long as you are
where it can see you you will never know
peace again now go check out
scp-1471 Mal o version 1.0.0 and scp-966
sleep killer for more Relentless
anomalies that'll seriously interfere
with your sleep schedule